okay I guess uh let's get started this
is the last lecture
of this course
I guess um um we're gonna continue with
the
um the special approach for clustering
so
um I pre-write some of them
um reviews of the last lectures I guess
um
so last lecture I think we did the
sarcastic blog model and one of the main
findings is that
um if you do I cantic conversation
um so our goal was to do again
implementation on the graph G
um from the sarcastic product model and
we have shown that if you do eigenetic
position on the average craft Gene the
expectation of Gene then just gives the
hidden Community SNS bar where the
um I think last time we showed that the
second act eigenvectors is something
called U which will look like one one
one and minus one minus one
um and this is s and this is S4 so
basically if you just take the second
eigenvector of the expecting graph G
then you get uh the uh the hidden
community
so and and we have argued that it's a
question to show that the graph G and
the expectation graph expectation G are
close enough in the operator norm and
this is because if you consider uh this
equation right so you subtract the first
eigenvalue from G and then what you get
is that g minus the first eigenetic
component is equal to this perturbation
Matrix plus the contribution of the
second econometric and if you take the
eigen the conversation of this Matrix
which is something you can compute
um easily then or you're getting a plot
argument Vector of the left hand side of
this equation then on
and then
um you you are expected to find
something close to you and as long as G
minus expectation G is something small
but how small it is I didn't really want
me to do this but essentially you need
this perturbation to be much smaller
than the signal right so you need a
perturbation in operating off much
smaller than the request signal you
operate or not and you can complete
operator for the reference signal very
easily which is sometimes P minus Q over
2 times n so basically we're trying to
show that the concentration right this
is a constitution inequality because you
are trying to prove that g concentrates
around expectation of gene in the
spectral nonsense
um I'd like to show you the proof this
is a lot of technical proof but the
proof is not very long and also it kind
of relates back to what we discussed in
lecture three or four where I guess
probably remember that I said that this
constitutional court is probably one of
the most important thing for this course
because this is this
kind of one of the if you pick one
technical Tools in statistical motion
learning I think it's probably
concentration inequality in my own
opinion so
um it's probably useful to just review
why uh the concentration equality can
help us to do something like this
so uh yeah I'll give a proof for this so
the proof look like
so we're going to prove that
so our Lemma is that
with high probability
G minus X factorization G in operator
Norm
is less than
square root and log n up to
constant Factor
so
um
and at the first side if this is not
exactly the type of concentration of
quality we have talked about before
because before we're talking about uh
scalars right we're saying that if you
have expectation of the if some random
variables have some empirical samples
and the empirical average consensus
around the uh the population on average
uh so here it's a little bit different
because G is the Matrix and the
expectation of G is also Matrix we are
doing some kind of like religious
concentration to some extent and your
measures of the the similarity is not
just the absolute value in the
difference of types value of the
difference but it's about something like
the optical Norm of the of the matrices
right of the differences of the matrices
so
um the
um however you can actually turn this
into something that we have we are
familiar with very easily so what you do
is the following so you say that uh this
is still uniform convergence as you see
customer ID
and why this is the case this is because
you can easily interpret Alternatives as
follows
so G minus expectation G
operator Norm
this is equals to
the max
over some
V let me write it down
explain so minus
this
is just because the Opera normal for
symmetric Matrix I think the definition
is you know if you have a symmetric
Matrix a
and and then the operator Norm I guess
there's absolute value here
it's the optional Norm of Matrix a is
the exactly equals to
the maximum quadratic form that you can
achieve by hitting it
with a non-one method
so
um and once you do this you see that
this becomes a scalar you know because
this quantity is a scale
and and you can decompose this into max
probably into an arm square and then you
get
V transpose GB minus V transpose
expectation GB
and this is a sum
so what is this maybe let me write down
more explicitly
this Max
this is sum of v i v j g i j
i j
to both are in the area and
minus
the expectation of this random version
and now this becomes some
of Independence
random variables and this becomes the
expectation of of this sum of
independent human variables
so now you can use Constitution if you
don't have the max you can use
concentration points but this is what
exactly half in the quality is for and
and how do you deal with the max right
so so then the max this will be the part
about uniform convergence right recall
that the whole point of this like
constant like uniform convergence is
that if you fix the time with her
suppose you think of me as the parameter
so the point of viewing from converting
is that you can fix the parameter you
can use whole thing in college to prove
the concentration to prove that
empirical is not far away from
population
and the challenge of uniform convergence
is about how do you take the Max and
here you still have a Max
so
so I guess you know there are multiple
ways to deal with this concentration of
course the easiest way is probably just
invoke some existing serum they are
discount Series in the literature as
well
um but if you want to do it yourself I
guess there are two ways so one way is
that you can use um
use the the rather marker complexity
machinery
to provide more complexity machinery
I guess I'm it's probably it's a while
back like we have we discussed this like
probably 10 weeks five weeks ago
um and and I think one of the techniques
is that you do symmetrization
right so so far this is not a
symmetrical form and you introduce some
random random marker variable and you
symmetrize it and then you can proceed
with all the run you can essentially
view this as a random Market complexity
of some function costs so you can go
with that I think that's actually pretty
clean and nicely I'm going to leave this
um you know if you're interested in you
can do it yourself I believe it's not
very difficult
um whatever so here is that I'm going to
show us even a lot of Brute Force
methods which use actually the that's
the first Technique we introduced in our
in your class the good Force
this conversation recall that before we
talk about weather Market complexity we
said that in many cases actually you can
just deal with the continuous function
class the uniform convergence for
continuous function costs with a very
simple
um
discretization so
um and and what we do is that so what we
do here is going to be just that you
um
perfectly
um with
two normally equal to one we can use
whole thing inequality
is hoping
so what you get is that
with probability
at most
um exponential minus
Epsom square root two I guess I'm not
expecting to check it you know on the
flight but you can just basically plug
in the off opt inequality
um without much without any modification
you can vibj gij
is close to its expectation
um
okay so the probability that it devices
from expectation is at most exponential
minus Epsilon Square over two and then
you can
Epsilon to be something like being all
of square root and log n so that your
failure probability then this means that
exponential minus Epsilon Square Over N
this is something like exponential minus
being all and login
this is a
pretty small failure probability
and then you take a display position
um
this colonization
of the unique ball
of um with
granularity
something like
um some of our polio
right this is what we did you know it's
a long time ago I know but I think this
is what weather is on lecture story I
think you take a very very very very
icon
precise or like a you use a very small
granular routine but it doesn't really
matter because at the end of the day the
dependency on the granularity is only
logarithmic so your size to the size of
this
of this cover
is on exponential and logic
and then you can take a unima
over this this screen size descriptions
so and then um because your granularity
is very small right it's only inverse
poly so you only lose inverse falling
and inverse power is smaller than any of
this point is so then basically
eventually you got that you take a unit
Bond regard with high probability
uh you have this
foreign
Epsilon which is chosen to be scored and
open
so I guess I'm skipping a lot of details
because I think today we don't have a
lot of time to complete
um all the materials so so I'm making a
brief but I think you can have got the
rough points and if you work out
it wouldn't take too much time to work
for details
um and I I kind of like this matter too
you know if I I were to say my
preferences between these matters
sometimes I like the matter too because
you can do this very quickly yourself
and you know exactly what dependencies
you know where the pennies come from and
if you do the right amount complex they
will be much cleaner you will get better
constants you'll get cleaner proofs but
sometimes it's a little bit less
transparent because you have to go
through this whole Machinery
um
and and why this is useful right this is
useful because now we've got this Lemma
right the Lemma is that the the G and E
extraction G is only different different
on other Scrolls and and you can compare
that with the signal so now
so compare
the knowledge level which is all
underscore log and versus the signal
level which is
p over Q times n
and P minus Q over two times n so then
this means that if P minus Q is much
bigger than 1 over square root than then
can recover
the signal
the vector U
approximately
so so we can see that you know you only
need pmq to have some separation but not
a lot of separate and the separation
depends on the size of the graph which
also makes some sense because the more
no importances you see the clearer where
the structure is in some sense you have
more kind of
like suppose you see a very it's
supposed to see two users right
everything is kind of two randoms for
you to tell who is which one is from
which Community but if you see a million
users you can use a lot of different
users to cross-validate in some sense
yourself and to impact the two
communities
all right so I guess this concludes the
the sarcastic followers model Parks
um I guess there are some other small
remarks which are not super important
um so so you can also actually
um
can improve the can
recover the exact community
um by by some post processing
so so here what I showed is that you
only come recover them you the vector U
approximately but actually you can post
processing to get the exact Community
under certain conditions I think under
the conditions like
um I'm getting here you can do it and
actually because this is a very precise
mathematical structure here so there are
a lot of works that's in in the
literature uh on this and you can
actually get exact even the exact
constant here so here I'm writing P
minus Q is larger than lower square
rooted so it's definitely very loose you
can get uh the precise dependencies
um that you need to recover and then you
can have the precise threshold below
that threshold you can't recover
anything above that threshold you can
recover something and above another
threshold you can recover exactly so so
all of these are uh in the literature if
you're interested
and you can extend this to multiple
blocks and so forth
okay so this company with the sarcastic
World model and now I'm going to move on
to
um uh another kind of very in my opinion
pretty important literature which is
about you know clustering the worst case
graph
and still the thing is that if you do
identity conversation you are gonna
recover some approximate
um uh structures in the graph
but the analysis will be different
because here we don't have the sarcastic
scene from the graph
so
um and and because you have a worst case
graph you have also somehow Define what
what do you mean by the hidden Community
right so because before in a stochastic
graph you start with Community you
generally graph and now you understand
the graph the graph is just some areas
you have to say what you're trying to
recover
so so let's start with that what what
what's what's our goal so this requires
us some definitions so let's give a
little
graph
Gene because the vertices is called E
and I just is called
um e a sort of radius is called V and
address is called B
um so let's define this so-called
conductance this is actually a pretty
um important notion which shows that in
many different areas of math so of
course inside different forms so here is
a particle I just about graph analysis
in other cases you can you can
conductors in high dimensional space as
well which are essentially the same
definition but look it could look a
little bit different
so uh the conductance for graph so
you're supposed to have a cost
that's called as an Xbox right you cut
the graph into two parts I send that
form and the conductance of s is defined
to be the following so you have
the number of edges between us and S Bar
over the volume of us
let's define both of this more
clearly so e is S Bar this is the total
number of edges
from X to S Bar but this is the
undirected graph there is no maybe I
should call it between asset as well
excuse me it's precise
so and which you know mathematically
this is really a sum of I
over I strain is bar g i j if gij if I
use g i j i so this is C Matrix
um I'm over using the notation a little
bit G both
develops the graph and also this is
mainly photograph
and the volume of s
this is the total number of ideas
uh total
total number
ages connecting
to us so which means that
you look at how many edges satisfies
that one unemployment easiness
so R is needs to be us and J can be
anything
and you have gig
so if you draw a graph something like
this
suppose your jaw graph
because
this is this
and you you define this card suppose
This Is Us then what is ES4 so ESS bar
will be Counting
these two right edges
because this is from s to S4
and and the volume of x will be counting
all the edges connected to us so which
means basically all that I just drawn
here
all the green outages are common
so and you can see that by the
definition it's true that the volume of
s is always
okay so what this definition is for this
is trying to characterize how
I guess as con the word conductance
indicates it's currently characterized
how how good the cut is in some sense
like how separate as an S Bar the
smaller it is the more separate the SNS
part is but you do have to normalize
um by the modeling right so so in some
sense in the number of areas you draw
the between is and S Bar is already
capturing
how separated analysis bar or but you
want to normalize with the volume to
make it more meaningful I guess that's
what I will argue in the next so I guess
before that let me just get some
basic informations the volume of us is
bigger than
the
uh the number of edges between is and S
Bar that's trivial so this means that
conductance is always less than one and
you are trying to make a conduction as
small as possible
another thing is that the volume of
earth plus the volume of S Bar
is equals the volume of V
this is the total number of edges right
so
um and and that means that
um so this means that
um if
um
the volume of s
is less than the volume of V over 2 then
the volume of s is also less than the
volume of
as far
and this means that the conductance of s
is bigger than the conductance supply
so so there's something so so you should
have a definition that somehow doesn't
mean planned on
how do you name is bar SNS bar is
symmetric but here the conductance of S
and S Bar are different
right so so that's why to kind of like
remove this symmetry confusion between
the Symmetry you just insist that you're
always talking about
so when we assist
that we always talk only talk about
as such that
the conductance of us uh sorry the
volume of class is less than
is less than the volume of B over 2. so
you're only taking a smaller part of us
and use that to define the conductance
of the cut
whatever we like why would you define
inductance so that we're going inspired
on your feet why don't yes so if you're
not normalize by the value of V For
example the problem is that it means
they really normalize because V is a
constant you have to normalize against
something I guess I'm going to tell you
why you have to normalize but if you
want to normalize you have to normalize
with something that changes as has
changed right so uh here I'm only trying
to deal with the Symmetry for so far
it's like a uh you'll only kind of
conductance on the smaller set
this is not really that much because you
don't want to cheat by saying that I
have a very very sad large title that I
only have like one one point in Ice Bar
and I it sounds like my contact is very
small but actually it's so you should
mention the the other the other side
okay so but now let's go um now let's uh
okay so maybe
maybe before proceeding answer the
question why we have to normalize so we
have to define the V of G this is the
conductance of the this is the fastest
card
this is the spark
the so-called sparse is cuts
uh of G
as process card value is defined to be
the minimum possible conductance but
again you require that as is less than
is the smaller side of the
the
um the two cards so you minimize over
the conductance of us
um and you minimize the conductance
First with the concern that the volume
of s is less than the volume of wheel
so you know we basically you just want
to find a card that is has smallest
conductors
and now let's talk about normalization
so why we have to normalize
questions
I think the the reason is pretty much
just because you know if you don't
normalize
uh if you don't normalize
then uh if you just minimize right if
you just look at
e
as as far as some would minimized it's
typically minimized when ice is small
thank you
so suppose you draw a graph for example
I guess
um
so if you only if you don't I mean if
you don't normalize basically you prefer
to pick a stack as that is itself is
very small so that it doesn't connect to
the other parts
so so for example let's see
suppose you have a graph like this
okay I guess I'm okay what I'm doing
here is I have a
suppose you have a completely connected
subgroup
right so you have over two nodes and
over two nodes and and within each of
the sub graph we have complete
connection with each other and then you
have some connections
some very small number of connections
between them maybe every node is
connected two of them
something like this
okay so it sounds pretty clear that you
should do really the best cut you should
get is is this is this bumper
because within the cluster you have full
connection and you're across the two
clusters you are for some number of
let's say two energies per per note so
if it sounds pretty clear we should do
this but if you look at
if you use the metric e as
as far then you'll see that some other
Cuts will have smaller number of edges
across the thing because you can just
take
this to be S1
because the ice minus contains one node
so then e of S1
ES1 S1 bar is basically how many edges
comes from S1 to S1 bar basically the
number of edges connected to S1 this is
n over two
but the the good cut let's say let's say
the good part is as two
so e as2 as 2 bar is definitely
something bigger than L over two because
you have n over two probably times
the the number of
green energy the number of blue edges I
know something like two here but I'm
joining
basically two are two edges per note
that's right so so so so basically even
it sounds like you should get S2 but if
you use the
normalized version then you would guide
to X1
so however if you normalize then it's a
different game right so if you normalize
if you look at the conductance of S1
then this is e of S1 S1 bar over the
volume of S1
this is over 2 times over L over two I
think the volume one plus flies
uh
L over two so this is one so if you look
at
field
as
two
then this is
this is uh
ten over two times
two something like this and then you
have the total number of I just
connected us to that's actually a big
number there's probably something like
over two times over two minus one this
is the number of ideas we didn't ask two
and there are some ideas between us to
an S2 bar something like this and this
would be something like roughly
I think two over n
so so the conduct can surprise two is
much smaller than conductance plus one
economized
questions so far
foreign
is to find
approximate
sparse is cut
meaning
that you want
as high to satisfies that the field has
had is close to the sparse as possible
cut V of G
foreign
conversation
so
how do I do this
um
okay I need a
okay there's just for us to even say to
what we mean exactly like a conversation
and the working of like a result
so first of all let's
d i
uh to be the volume
of the
node I right you take a single node you
take the volume this is d i and this is
really just the degree
of uh node I
right so the volume of the anode is
really the degree of the node unless can
be
to be the diagonal matrix that contains
bis engine
and let's define this
so-called normalized adjacent symmetrics
it's called a bar which is the C minus a
half
G times D major half
so where G is an adjacency Matrix recall
this is our notation
which is a lot of beautiful Plantation
so what is this mean what does this
really mean this really just means that
I guess you have one over Square v i d
one up to one over square root B and
times G times more square root d one up
to one square root even
and a diagonal matrix Multiplied on the
left means that you
your scale
all of the roles and the other Matrix on
the right hand side as a right hand side
multiplication means you scale all the
columns so basically you scale The
Columns and row simultaneously with
these numbers but you can do the exact
equation whatever it means is that
the aij the ijs entry of the normalizer
this is the Matrix is really just a The
adjacency Matrix over square root d i
Times Square DJ
so this sounds a little bit complicated
but in most of the cases you know I'm
almost dating this mostly for formality
because you know
um
um it sometimes the key thing it can be
seen by assuming the graph is regular so
so in most cases
suffices to
uh think of
GUI as a regular graph
a regular graph means that all the
degrees
are the same
so let's say suppose I think G is a cut
our regular graph
meaning D is is equals to Kappa for
every I then
is adjacency Matrix is really just a one
over Kappa not much of this system
Matrix is one over copper times gig
so in some sense you really didn't do
much except that just changing the
scaling of this that but this game is is
kind of like important in the in the
formula sense because it's going to make
the performer very clean but it's not
fundamentalist
um super important
um
so so this is pretty much the if you
like you if you don't want to think
about the the DI DJs you pretty much can
think of this simple case where you have
a regular graph
okay so and once you define the
normalized or just since the Matrix you
can also Define the soap plus laplacian
Matrix
which is I minus the normalized
adjacency Matrix
I think you'll probably see that one of
the reasons why we have to normalize is
that if you don't normalize it doesn't
make sense to subtract take the
differences between it and and identity
I don't think it's something that
doesn't have a scale so you have to
normalize this so that you can kind of
take the diff with analytic
and and this is laplacian matrix it's
really not doing that much
it's not that different from normal so
this is Matrix anyway because they are
pretty much like everything corresponds
to each other right so like the ideal
vector
of IO is the same as
the eigenvector
of a bar and the spectrums are just
flipped with each other so let's say
suppose suppose
L has
hi guys
value along the one up to London and
that's it force that I think in this
literature you always want to
you always want to kind of like um
um order them
and then with
say eigenvalue eigenvector
say U1 up to U1
then this means that this is equivalent
to a bar
as eigenvalue
one minus Lambda one
up to one minus on the end now I'm
starting in
this decreasing order and and with
eigenvector
uh the same Mega vectors
right so
um but as you'll see like at the rate so
far so you don't even have to think
about the laplacian right the LaPlace
will come into play at some level later
faces but so far you can just think of
black nationalism it's a flip version of
normalizer this is nothing really
so
okay so these are some a little bit
abstract preparations
um and now let's see what we can do with
this so the
this is the of the
in my opinion pretty
important zero is continuous inequality
actually use the dates back to 1969 by
Jeff Tigger so it says the following
uh it says that Lambda 2 this is the
second eigenvalue
over 2 is less than the conductance of G
Which is less than square root 2 Lambda
2.
so it connects so why this is a very
important thing it connects the
conductance the cuts the spices cut to
something linear algebra to the eigenous
vectors right so so the smartest cut is
a very combinatorial stuff where you
have to if you really want to find this
versus card you probably want to
enumerate all the possible parts and to
find spices and this is the definition
requires it's a combinatorial thing and
but this inequality is saying that
somehow the smallest the smartest cut
value has a lot to do with the
eigenvalues of the lambduction of the
agencies Matrix
um and in particular it has it's very
close to the second eigenvalue of the
LaPlace images
and moreover you can also find the
you can find
the approximately cut as hat
such that
this cut as as the conductance is less
than square root 2 Lambda 2 Which is
less than two Times Square Root V of G
um efficiently computational inflation
three
and not only computation efficiently but
also actually pretty efficiently what we
can do with the following
um by
rounding the eigenvectors I guess
rounding really means the following
this is the wrong thing in the
the approximation algorithm size I guess
you know if you don't know where the
current comes from it doesn't matter so
here's the procedure to find such as
setbacks hats so suppose you take U2
suppose
to U2 is equals to
the coordinates are available
is the second argument it's a second
lecture
um and
so you can
take
a threshold which is
um
and consider
the set I expect I to be
all the coordinates
that satisfies the ability is less than
tall
so take a threshold but you don't have
to consider all the possible threshold
it's not
necessary because
um and you see so you take a threshold
and the threshold is chosen from one of
these colonies and you say you look at
all the coordinates that are smaller
than this threshold
and that's your set as headlight
and then while this so you have
basically any of these stats right as
one head as two heads as three heads and
so forth so one of this
has high eyes
satisfied
feel as a height is less than 2 Times
Square Root V
so while this side will be a good cut so
so I guess I'm sticking this in a slack
in a formal way so that it seems to be a
little confusing so what you really are
doing is the following so you sort so I
guess in in plain language or in more
click
in formal language you serve first the
sort of the coordinates
suppose you sort of opponents first and
you get beta 1 less than beta 2 so
and then it's saying that if you take
this this will be as kind of R right
this will be the first I I coordinate
and that would and while this part will
be uh a good cut
so you can try one card which is like
this you can try another card which is
better one better two and you can
another try another card which is better
one better two after beta I and one of
these cards will be a good cut for the
graph with small conductors
uh and of course you have to restart the
you have to remark the coordinates back
to the original coordinate system
because you have soldering the chords
um
questions
foreign
but here you don't know where the exact
special should be you should try all the
thresholds
um
um beta one up to Beta and all of them
Okay cool so this is a pretty you know
magical theorem in my opinion
um
um
I'm not going to prove it I think they
are you know if you are interesting I
think there are a lot of black notes
blacker notes that um can improve this
um
um I guess what I'm gonna do is that I'm
going to
sign exactly
yeah and and if you are able to you know
and you can enumerate all of them I see
which one satisfied
foreign
[Music]
so I'm gonna skip the proof I'm gonna
link
I see some questions here
so the question online here is that the
hack SJ found this way isn't the best
possible cut right
um yes so you
you are not guaranteed to find the best
possible cards you are only guaranteed
to find a card such that the card value
field sshi satisfies that it's less than
two Times Square Root field
if you've got a few of you here suppose
suppose you magically change this to V
of G
then that means you can best talk
because P of T is the value of the best
part of course we believe there are much
more bus stops as well but you you
definitely find one of the best cuts uh
but however we don't have that strong
material we only show that it's Square
Two Times Square Root be okay because
um uh so you lose something right square
field G is bigger than P of G by the way
because C of T is less than one so so
you lose some um some factor in terms of
like uh the best possible uh Vector
conductors
I hope that answers the question
how does you have to lose a little bit
into some extent because to some extent
because
I guess this is sometimes postmortem
like like um but if you think about it
like in retrospect you know one of this
quality is very combinatorial
the the spices class and the other point
is very linear algebraic
sounds unlikely that they can be exactly
the same right so
um
um so it's already unfortunately that
they are somewhat related in my opinion
um and I also kind of like the mostly
discuss some of the intuitions or kind
of the kind of like more basic
um
qualities or um like some of the
intuitions why this can be possible too
but I wanted to build the whole group
the statement of the parent so that we
can find people start such that less
than square root two level two yeah
which then is less than like is that
what we're actually finding that we're
just saying that o by this you know
currently probably one or whatever
um then that's less than two square root
50 and in that case like
right
you just care about the comparison of R
but the cut of G as it could like it's
not significant because
like the square roots you lend it to
business significant other than that it
was assume is that one
uh sure okay so uh yes so first of all
yes you are right so how do you get this
inequality this is just by using this
part right so that's true and second yes
probably the first other video I care
about is comparing with Cog and this is
just the start making media things yeah
um
um however
um
yeah that's the that's the first
Olympics but I think if you look at the
proof you do have to like somehow the
arguments have to show up somewhere so
so
like do not produce
um is actually pretty good
um because for two Lambda 2 it actually
relatively small but then you lose more
in that same kind of quality I think
it's possible but we don't really know
like it's it's kind of like very hard to
I I think I think they are a hard
instances in both cases like in like
this thing can be both close to feet on
October two or it could be very close to
this this side
yeah
um cool so
I guess I'll focus on some intuitions
and why like the first thing I'm going
to discuss is that
um I think this is again about the
skating and and and
um to some extent so so first of all the
smallest architecture why you take the
second actor I think that's always
something that seems to be magical to me
uh at the first side I learned
um after I spent some time with your
wife what personalities I didn't realize
the the the the topic like I said kind
of like say last time the topic is kind
of like a background so either the
smallest eigenvector
of L or the top eigenvector
of a bar this is kind of like not that
interesting
and what why it's not interesting is
pretty much only trying to get the
only capturing the in some sense
I call it background it's kind of like a
background density
so what I really mean by this is that of
the graph
what I really mean by this is that let's
say suppose but she is Kappa regular
then we know that I think reactions I
have said this in the previous lecture
so
um all my Vector is top eigenvector
of
a
of the of G
of the adjacency Matrix and thus
also
top eigenvector
of
a bar which is just one Kappa times G
right so
so when G is regular then the top angle
Vector is really just about it's just a
online vector
and when in more General case
it's really just involves the scaling
based on density
so what more General G what happens is
that the top eigenvector is really just
this one
it's very D1 up to square B1
the scaling doesn't matter here because
the unique the eigenvector signal I mean
multiplication of this is also I
remember so I I didn't care about the
scaling so this is the top eigenvector
of a bar so small is which means the
smallest eigenvector
of
of
of Laplace
right why this is the case you can
verify this very easily so a bar times
U1
this is the machine location and you
look at the JS coordinate ice coordinate
this is equals to the sum of J over J
sum of a i j Bar times u j
and aij bar is a scaled version of the
graph so gij
over square of d i square root DJ
and u j is square root DJ
and this is the sum over J so so you
first
has all these two and you get one over
Square D i in front you get this
and recall that this is actually process
definition of the degree this is the
um total number of edges connect to the
graph so get one respond b i times e i
which is square root EI
so that verifies that U1 is an eigen
left
this means a bar U1 is equal to U1
so basically as before the top item
actor is not doing much it's really just
capturing the density the degrees of the
of the graph and the second eigenvector
starts to talk about the the
interconnections it has more about the
the relationship between ideas and and
kind of hidden communities
and now let's look at
um some
instructions about why this
um
um why
the laplacian like why the the why like
somehow these eigenvectors is related to
the cut so here is a another way to
think about it
so if you look at the
quadratic form of the laplacian
so what is this this is the mean
transpose I times V minus V transpose a
bar times B
that's just brutally put firstly writers
this is sum of the I Square I from 1 to
n minus
the sum of
i j
um I guess let's do it e i v j a bar i j
and this is sum of e i Square
minus some b i b j g i j
square root d i square root DJ
and gij is one when I use one
so what we got is that sum of bi squared
minus
i j is an edge
I guess g but I J and J I are both ID so
that's why you get a 2 here
so
um VI over Square D I
as v j over square root DJ
and now you can break this first thing
um I and then you take
j v i
uh
I guess maybe that's right this way so
I'm claiming that this will is equals to
sum of VI over Square bi minus v j over
Square DJ
squared and I J is in e
and and why this is true this is true
you know you can expand this inequality
this this equation into terms and you
can see the cross term matches this one
the only thing is to see the other terms
match the VI's right so we can verify
that by looking some i j
in e v i Square over
d i
uh
as this is
um
sum over I sum of J
such that
I J and E
number okay I guess I think this is
probably obvious but
I'm making a little bit too complicate
so we are square over d i comes this way
if you sum over I first and sum over j7
or if we're sum over 2 and then some
over I so how many edges are connected
to I that's basically d i so you guys
this v i Square
over d i times d i
so
let's buy some more so here score
Okay so
okay sounds good
so the point here is that I guess I'm
somehow missing a constant somewhere I'm
not sure what
I did yeah it's a constant somewhere
um I think the the constant might be off
by two somewhere but
um but again it is right
um
okay so and if this is regular rough if
if G is regular bro say copper regular
then you can ignore the eyes you can
just uh say V transpose LV is one over
Kappa times
I J and E
v i minus B J Square
okay so but why I care about is why
there's so much work to and I've got
this equation that the equation is very
important because this is how it links
to how this algebraic quantities links
to the conductance right so this is
still a large algebra quality it's
something like linear algebraic right
it's a quadratic form
however if you hear suppose now you you
restricted restrict me to be binary so
suppose
me is it take me to the binary
uh is a binary vector
and you take us to be the support of the
right so
the the indices where the answer is the
V is one
then you can see that from this
foreign transpose LV is more over Kappa
times
e
uh V IMS VJ Square
and when this is one this is one when I
and J
are in both are in different uh so this
is only one
if
I and S and J is in X bar or I is in S4
J is in s
right so so basically you know the sum
is the number of edges between us and S
Bar because only when the inj is the
eyes across the groups
this this vmx VJ square is because one
otherwise is equal to zero
so this is why it's one over Kappa times
the number of edges across
so the quadratic form connects to
the
the number of projects across the two
groups will V is not binary if V is not
binary or Force it's not true but if it
is binary it's true so and now
uh all the other words you can write V
transpose LV is
for Kappa
the support of me
is important
so and now suppose if
the support of me
the size is less than over two so you
have the volume is less than so this
means that
the volume of this s is less than the
volume
of B over two
because this is a regular graph the
volume is really just the size of the
set and then in this case v transpose LV
over
this this
um ratio V transpose LV over the norm of
V Square
this becomes one over a couple times the
number of varieties between X and S Bar
and what is the volume of what is the
mean of course this we know before is
really the size
this is just equal to size of s the size
of ice is really just the volume of s
over copper
right the volume is the number of edges
connected to us and it's regular graph
that's where the volume is just couple
times the side effects so then you
cancel the copper you get you as far
over the volume of us
so this is the conductance of us
so basically conducting device
can be written as this this form
and this form is some kind of linear
algebraic form and I think this there's
so this is we transpose LV over Norm of
V this is called
really
quotient
and and I think this is the name of this
this is named really quotient and the
point here is that it's really important
connects to the conductance
but of course it's not
exact because it requires when V is
better
right so if you do other vectors you are
trying to do either letters
thank you means you are minimizing
really quotient
uh without any without any constraints
right
questions
follow me
right
but uh the minimum conduct is the sparse
is cut
basically means minimize
really quotient
with the binary constraint
and in some sense the secrets apology
the core is really that
even without a constraint with the
constraint without constraint you don't
really
think about that much
so actually the the proof works out like
something like you first try to
um
the fun eigenvectors and then you
somehow you get some real number of
means that the the
eigenvectors have real numbers right in
B and then you're wrong you run it into
binary vectors and then you say by
rounding it you don't lose too much of
the radio quotient and that's how the
proof uh roughly speaking works
so
um
intuition
and all of this you know can be extended
to where the graph like the information
is the same for one year graph
um or for none by none like for
graphs that are not similar not not
regular and also for graphs that are
weighted right so here the graphs are
just fine we're like zero one there's no
one in other words you can also do it
forward
okay so great so I think I hope that I'm
convinced you that the eigenvectors are
very related to the graph clustering
by these two examples stochastic block
model and and this worst case situation
and this kind of like algorithm has been
used so if you do this on a special
classroom this is a
um
like um
and you can actually use this like a
um okay how do I say this so the
materials I presented this mostly come
from the theoretical conversations
Community
um and I'm there uh it doesn't have much
to do with machine learning right so
what the people care about is that you
just want to partition a graph into two
clusters so you don't have to know
machine learning to define a problem to
study this and
um I think
um like there are there's a so-called
special classroom approach
special classroom
this was brewed to our machine Learning
Community I think around 200 I think by
I guess I said this paper
um by She and Malik
and in Jordan
was
one
thousand
and the way that you do it is that you
you define graph from the machine
learning right now and then you apply
this algorithm
so so basically this
um brings us to question how to choose
this graph
so how to choose
our design graph
because the graph you know in TCI the
graph is given to you maybe some some
graph then somebody they view but in
machine learning you have to somehow
choose your ground
right so in the uh in the Andrew and
newspaper
um the definition of the graph is
something like this so you first say
you you give me some raw data
the X1 after excellent so these are
untraining later points
and then you define the graph G
uh to be
something like g i j this is a weighted
graph you know I would I didn't really
discuss the way they graph but there's a
natural extension to where the graph and
then the way around the waves between
rnj is something like exponential minus
x i minus x j to Norm over two Sigma
squared I guess this is probably
something that is very familiar to you
this is just the rbr kernel the the
gaussian currency
so Define this uh with some training
parameters or you can have some other
virus right so
I guess you can find a graph based on
some distances between the fewer
examples
uh and then what you do is you say uh
you do this you get a special class you
run you get the eigen letters
so so so first I will Define a group of
three and get eigenvectors of the
LaPlace
a normalized adjacency matrix
and and here you know it's not only two
clusters you can do multiple clusters
and when you do multiple clusters what
you do is you say you get eigenvectors
um
say U1 U2 up to UK suppose you want to
have K cluster
and this is the Matrix of dimension
R of and by K right so so each column is
a
is the eigen vector and you have three
of these eigen vectors and now what you
do is you say you take the rows as the
embeddings
or in the modern world you call it
representation because you know I
probably some of you heard of
representation learning so
and for the for the the IFA example
so basically you can like so for every
example x i now it becomes represented
as
maybe let's call it 0 v i
v i which is the dimensional head
and K is K it corresponds to how many
eigenvectors you take
and then you can develop the machine
organizations maybe tell you something
like two or three and then and in the
original paper of Andrew's paper I think
you do some kind of other another
training classroom some other classrooms
okay means
I'm not I guess probably heard of
cleanings okay means on the
representations
to you
um I'm going to Cluster them again so
this is the uh the so-called spectral
classic algorithm and they were actually
later I think around 2014 2013 there
were a few papers that analyze this
um and and so that you can actually get
reasonable
um repetitions and clusters by using
this approach
any questions
so so what are the what's the issue with
this the issue with this
is that the graph G could be not very
meaningful
so in high dimension
so all the data points are very far away
from each other
are all the training data points that
should be very precise
far away from each other
so so this uh under your green distance
becomes you know like Ukraine distance
between these three little points
becomes pretty much minimalist
because
um
um because if you take it you clean this
install for cat and dog versus the
difference between dog and dog you
probably wouldn't see much differences
because two dogs could still have very
big euclidian distance
um two random dogs
so and I think this is the the in some
sense the problem uh with with the graph
itself is not meaningful so if you find
the sparse's class for the graph if the
graph itself is not very useful even
finding a sports card is not that
important it's not that useful uh uh for
you so that's why the serial analysis
for this special classic algorithm you
know it doesn't really kind of deliver
that much because it didn't really
consider how the graph was generated
right all of this Theory says that if
you're given a good graph you can find
as much as cut for this one using this
approach but it doesn't really say
anything about how the graph is
generated
so I think for the last the last 15
minutes I'm going to discuss
um briefly discuss one of the my uh this
is one of the working line uh in my
group uh recently so where we try to
reuse this um classical idea but use it
for
um um in a different way so so this is a
um
so this is in one of his paper by Halton
at all in my group so what we are trying
to do is that we say you consider
infinite graph
thank you
so g v w so this is the vertices
this is the weights on edge
and where we take me to be
um
all the possible inputs
so the this is the all possible
um data data points
so this graphically depends on the
population space right so so X is the
basically space of all possible say
images and your graph is defined on each
each image corresponds to vertex so
before the graph has size little and
sorry this is e
so before the graph I started later on
right it's a little unbelievable Matrix
and now the graph has a much bigger size
the size is is the same as the
cardinality of all possible data points
which could be Infinity
so
um so it's possibility maybe let's say
for example let's say let's say you have
find a number of possible images
but in
could be exponential
so possibilities let's say we have
exponential size graph
um
so then
um
what you can so on this graph what you
what you do is you Define w x x Prime
the
the weight between two nodes two
vertices
um let's say the fund needs to be large
only
when
x and x Prime are closed
are closing
how to do this
so I'm still using how to distance I'm
still probably using you know I didn't
I'm not that's not exactly what's the
definition here because I think that
requires too much Dragon which I can
operate in 10 minutes but still we are
using pretty much you can think of this
as almost the same as the the previous
definition of the graph when X and X2
Prime are closed but I guess the point
is that this is very close
so before you have to choose the sigma
very very subtly because all the points
are very far away from each other right
so but now you say that I don't have all
those points that far away from each
other I just care about those two points
that are very close to each other right
so suppose you have two dogs random dogs
you say they are not blocks if you only
have one lock and then you have a
permutation perturbation of that same
note you say there are two there are
dogs that are connected each other
so then this graph becomes more
renewable because you only connects very
nearby cats and dogs
um uh or convert nearby images and then
the so the graph becomes more meaningful
so the the pros is that
the graph is more meaningful
I guess the cause is that it becomes
infinimensional
and you don't have this graph because
you don't know all the possible data
points uh you only have some sample data
points
um
um so or infinite or exponential
expansion
dimension
and you don't have access to this graph
foreign
so the way we fix the cons is the
following so and also maybe another way
cause is that the um even the eigen
vector itself right the eigenvector
uh is also High dimensional right
right it's infinite dimension
because the eigenvector the mass of the
eigenvector is the same as the dimension
of the of the graph
so however on here what we are doing is
that we
um use the
the new ideas the different ideas into
kind of actually the real research is
the reverse direction we somehow try to
explain the different ideas but here in
this context you know you can think of
this as use the parametric numerator
kind of ideas to try to deal with this
class so what you'll do is you say
suppose you have argument from you this
is the ID vector
so this is the iPhone
you and and here the eigenvector is a
high dimensional Vector so you can say
this in ux word is index size all the
possible data points uh in the vector X
right this is the off Dimension
something like maybe R2 to the capital N
or or to the infinity depending on how
many vertices uh in your set so and you
don't even have you know space to save
all of this even it's a single act like
you don't have any space to save it but
what you do is you say you represent
uh this U
U sub X by
a
new network applied on the
um on a raw data point x
so where
X Theta is
a parameters model
so if you do this then at least you can
describe diagram marker by Theta now you
don't have to specify all the capital N
numbers
um
on to specify the eigenvector you only
have to specify the Theta to to describe
this argument of course you know there's
a you know if you believe that acceler
is powerful enough then you can express
any letters but of course you know I've
said the problem would have been enough
so you have to make some assumption that
you might Works can represent these kind
of like conductors but suppose under
that assumption then you can at least
represent the eigenvectors uh by by
Theta and now basically the question
becomes like so the question changes to
um you want to find Theta
such that
this Vector F Theta X right is very high
dimensional vector
is an eigenvector
of um
of the graph G
so at least you're trying to find a low
dimensional part you're trying to find a
parameter Theta right you are not trying
to find the a high dimensional Vector
anymore
and it turns out that if you uh do this
foreign
[Music]
basically trying to do the
this gives a
H you can you can use that algorithm to
try to achieve this I guess I'm trying
to let me see whether I have time to
I guess what we can do is the following
so what you do is you say I'm going to
how do I find the eigenvector of L uh
like this so suppose I have the access
to the to the whole graph which I don't
but suppose I have it what I can do is
that I can minimize
the following thing so I can say I'm
going to minimize uh
let me write it down I'll
so
maybe let's do this this was interesting
any bar
I have is an invite images so first of
all I claim that this gives
the top item actor
of a bar
this is because
um this is some
something that's uh I probably wouldn't
have time to explain that much but if
you want to fit a long run Matrix
this is exactly the top K architecture
so if you want to play the no ramp
matrix 12 to the Matrix a bar
the best fetch would be to use the
eigenvectors of a bar
so so this is um
um this is local theorem to show this so
I've basically I've there's gonna be
some version of uh the minimize of this
will be some version of the isometric so
I think F will be the minimizer of this
will be some scaling of diagonometers
and then if you use this objective then
you can replace the capital F which is
non-parametric it's a very bit Matrix
side so you can say that you have to act
now for now is you supposed to be done
something like this right so and then
you write it as this you write it as
apps data X
uh
transpose X1 up to of theta extend
principles so you replace the role by
the parametrics version so you say that
every row now is a network of the raw
data
and then what you can get is that this
will be
if you write this as
in this version this is like first of
all you write the Forbidden storm as a
sum over i j in n a bar i j minus
uh so
I have FF transpose i j the ijs entry is
a the eye flow in the product with the J
flow
so that's why this is equals to
F Theta x i
times F Theta x j
x squared
and I can change this to instead of
minimizing up now you are minimize Theta
and I guess I don't have time to go
through all the details but you can this
is basically this is a no objection
function that you can optimize of course
the problem is that you still have this
sum this big sound you can replace this
by the empirical version
so you can get minimize over Theta you
can take
some random samples
so you can take
um
I guess I'm not sure whether
I'm going to Simply write this
so so you can stop okay maybe I'll just
say you can stop some photos
uh
estimates
using empirical examples
and and actually it turns out that if
you simplify this formula this will be
something similar to The contrastive
Learning algorithm
um that is used in practice I guess this
part I don't really have time to to show
I guess I'll refer you to the paper
um
I think probably I should just uh
stop here are there any questions first
about like this I know this part is a
little bit
um feel free to ask any questions
um the paper the I think probably it's
good to write yeah yeah I think like the
the loss is not exactly the contrast
deployment loss it was in practice so so
we're gonna have something we call
Spectral confessionals so which so
basically actually this step you know if
you have all the setup then I this stuff
is pretty cheap
um
um So eventually you simplify this a
little bit your what you want to get is
that you guys one term which is minus a
half I would say to x i
would say the XJ
uh and this is something like the
the term that tries to make two
examples closer to each other and
there's another term that turns to
contrast them but there's another so
um anyway so I guess I probably just
refer to the paper of our paper I think
the title of the paper is just
some improvable
self-supervised learning
while conscious spectral construction
laws sexual contrastive loss
something like this
um I think a problem is you can search
fantastic
the second just for this one new version
looking up like uh
and
uh say that corresponds to like the
first data points like what exactly is
that correspondent simply
how come if the first and the second
world are similar that the first two
vehicles should be similar
I I think I got a question
um so
I think there is something that I kind
of like I understand why there's a lot
of confusion because I escaped something
like about the the K how do you deal
with K clusters but I think this could
be seen when you have only
like if you take a little place between
plate passes and two passers you just
say this is too faster and then if you
look at the
let's see so where did we discuss this I
think we discussed this
is somewhat implicitous in several times
so I guess for example suppose you go
back to here
and recall that the second argument
looks like beta 1 up to Beta n
right so and we discussed that you take
a threshold and then you can separate it
to right it's threshold so so so in this
case basically suppose you have two
clusters and
in this case basically the beta I is our
practitioner of the if the vertex
so
so that's that's the real right that
beta Y is the first zero right beta 2 is
the second row right so beta R is the
representation of the ith vertex and Y
beta I is the the raw data I think this
is because
at least if your threshold by the eye
you get the works right so basically in
some sense when I
in some sense I mean you may be like
using music for it so you suppose you in
the stock password of model regardless
and then I guess you probably can't
worry that
these numbers are better repetitions
than the original data because now you
map all the
vertices in the same group to one right
so just uh you lost all the other
information you just to get the
reference station just exactly tells you
about the group membership
and you don't know anything about
elsewhere so the group membership is the
only thing you care about so
so that's why these numbers are more
like better web stations than uh this is
kind of similar to the like features
approximation
um and
[Music]
um you know that's just a better
representation because we've taken the
most important parts of representation
exactly and I know and what's the most
important one the most important one
here in this case the most important one
is the classroom structure right so
which group you belong to right so like
so that's why the only thing you have
like a I suppose if you think that's the
most important information that your
organization should just be that you
know any other information you just say
the group ID is my requestation and
that's the that's the best conversation
in this case we said there's two
clusters
but then you know we
wanna you care about like you know
the true clustered kind of
representation will be also declare
paramoto three cluster representation
and like how close things are based on
and it's about taking multiple lighting
vectors we can kind of uh get a bigger
picture than just like
in this cluster or not exactly exactly
so if you have more argument person you
can get three costing information or
even more information and also this can
be some of this information can be
recombined you can even bring your
information right so
um because eventually you probably use
this workstation
by linear cost user linear height on top
of it so so suppose you have two type of
information in your system then you
actually combine them to get more
information yes but you are right so
basically you get more argument because
you get more winter information from
them
yeah so essentially you are it's kind of
like major experimentation you distill
the information
in the graph to
um smaller amount of information I'm
looking at the question we are trying to
answer is what information you keep in
the arguments right so it's not
centralizing that diagonal numbers
has like a
more specific information about the
graph the question is what can mini
machine games and kind of the rough
intuition that it just keeps the the
clustering structure in a graph but not
other things right like I use the Low
Low Like the smaller second batteries
are trying to keep the customers
okay great I think this is this will be
the uh the end of the quarter I guess uh
I hope you like the course I guess we
discussed
um quite a bunch of topics and this
actually this college I think we covered
the most compared to all the previous
quarters because partly because we have
more than we have 10 minutes every every
every class and every lecture and also
we have two more while two more lectures
because we have fewer holidays in this
corner
um yeah I guess uh I hope you like it
thanks thanks so much for coming